good
[Music]
hello how are you I am sal y jaramillo with
the most outstanding headlines for
today wednesday september 16 the
nevada metropolitan and highway police are looking for a
murderer that's right the detectives
said a woman died on the
interstate  15 and flamengo was
originally thought to have been an accident
but during the investigation they
discovered that she was shot
and consequently crashed if someone
was traveling this road at
midnight they could have seen a
blue adverse mass please
contact the authorities
this  this week clark county will
hold a virtual meeting to
answer any questions the
public has about the upcoming
election you can attend this meeting
tomorrow at 6pm via
our facebook page or online at
our page  oficial and news now
dotcom diagonal in Spanish
and today ends the job fair for
the c  asino near las vegas located
in south downtown looking to hire
schwartz anders waiters and dancers you
must be over 21 to
apply you can do it through
alverson's official page and now
we go to the weather forecast
we will have a sunny and hot day  with
a maximum exceeding 100 degrees for
today, however, the temperatures will drop as we
approach the weekend and
the breezes will return to the valley. Have a good
day. I am salt and jaramillo and this was the
Spanish edition
[Music]